il pousse un peu partout autour de nous
à travers les forêts sur les arbres dans
nos jardins ni plante ni animal les
champignons sont une forme de vie unique
et parfois surprenante
un chercheur de l'université de l'ouest
du Royaume-Uni a fait une découverte
inusité à leur sujet un jour Adama ski a
constaté que les champignons se parlent
dans son laboratoire il a étudié quatre
espèces
la qualibi à pied velouté le schizophile
commun le champignon fantôme et le
champignon chenille
cette communication prend place à l'abri
des regards dans une partie du
champignon qui se trouve sous terre
il s'agit de lift une sorte de filament
qui s'étend sous le champignon comme les
racines d'un arbre
le réseau formé par ses filaments porte
le nom de mycélium et il connecte les
champignons entre eux ainsi qu'avec les
plantes environnantes
[Musique]
ces filaments envoient des impulsions
électriques comme le font nos cellules
nerveuses pour transmettre de
l'information
le professeur Anjou à damaski analysé
ses impulsions il a inséré de petites
électrodes dans le substrat sur lequel
poussaient les champignons ou dans le
cas du schizophrène commun sur la partie
immergée du champignon
il a constaté que ses impulsions
électriques ne sont pas aléatoires leur
durée et leur amplitude fluctue en
suivant des patrons récurrents qui
s'apparente à une forme de langage
en analysant les différents patrons
d'impulsion le chercheur a pu identifier
une cinquantaine de mots
et ces mots se succèdent pour former
différentes séquences comme dans une
phrase
parmi les quatre champignons étudiés le
schizophile commun et celui dont les
phrases étaient les plus complexes
le mystère maintenant et de savoir ce
que se disent les champignons
[Musique]
pour l'instant on ignore mais il est
possible qu'il se communique l'existence
d'un danger ou la présence de nutriments
il se peut également que cela leur
permettre de se localiser les uns les
autres
il faudra poursuivre les recherches pour
déchiffrer ce langage des choses
certaines les champignons n'ont pas dit
leur dernier mot
[Musique]